face à Poutine série documentaire
passionnante qui nous donne beaucoup
beaucoup d'éléments de compréhension sur
la stratégie de Vladimir Poutine est-ce
que tout cela ne nous éclaire pas un peu
aussi sur la diplomatie troublante qu'il
mène aujourd'hui parlons-en avec nos
invités Michel Valet bienvenue à vous
vous êtes sénateur socialiste de la
Charente Maritime secrétaire du Sénat
membre de la commission des affaires
étrangères de la défense et des forces
armées et je précise que vous êtes
diplomate de profession Sylvie Berman
bienvenue à vous également vous êtes en
ancien ambassadrice de France en Chine
au Royaume-Uni en Russie et vous êtes
l'auteur de ce livre madame
l'ambassadeur de Pékin à Moscou une vie
de diplomate aux éditions Talandier
Antoine vitkin bienvenue à vous
également journaliste écrivain
réalisateur de documentaires spécialisé
sur l'international vous avez vous-même
réalisé un documentaire passionnant
intitulé La Vengeance de Poutine et
arrive bientôt votre série documentaire
triade la mafia chinoise à la conquête
du monde pierre gonau bienvenue vous
êtes historien enseignant à la Sorbonne
à Sorbonne université à l'École pratique
des hautes études et vous êtes l'auteur
de la guerre russe ou le prix de
l'Empire divant le terrible à Poutine
aux éditions Talandier également
bienvenue à tous les quatre je le disais
énormément de choses dans cette série
documentaire on va procéder par ordre il
y a un élément qui m'a marqué et vous me
direz si ça vous a marqué vous aussi
c'est ce qu'on entend dans la bouche de
plusieurs chefs d'État et de diplomate
c'est cette technique du mensonge de
Vladimir Poutine Sylvie Berman est-ce
qu'il y a une diplomatie du mensonge de
Vladimir Poutine c'est un homme du KGB
et le mensonge est un outil utilisé par
le KGB donc il a finalement bien appris
cela il s'est séduire charmé
menacer ses interlocuteurs et en tout
cas il ment et il y a eu un épisode à
Paris au moment du sommet en décembre
20199 sur
le sur l'Ukraine où il avait accusé
zelensk de mentir Zelenski s'était
récrié et il lui dit mais si tu mens je
mens aussi vous mentez tous et on ment
tous ah il avait admis qu'il mentait
quand même ce qui était un peu nouveau
une première Antoine vitkin il ment
c'est une technique c'est même une
technique de lui et de ses lieutenant et
de ses troup on voit laavre qui m c'est
dit dans le documentaire ça va même plus
loin effectivement il vous fait
comprendre enfin on m'a rapporté cela il
vous fait comprendre qu'il sait que vous
savez qu'il ment ce qui est une manière
aussi d'imposer un rapport de force
lorsque l'autre sait que vous mentez
vous lui vous lui mentez il il y a un
épisode dans le documentaire que
François Hollande a lui-même rapporté
qui est le moment où à propos de la
Crimée euh Vladimir Poutine ni
absolument que la Russie soit impliquée
en dépit de toute évidence et donc c'est
une manière de poser un rapport de force
mais je pense que c'est plus large que
cela c'est pas seulement une diplomatie
du mensonge enfin une technique du
mensonge la Russie est capable de faire
de la diplomatie en en autrement que par
le mensonge pur mais il est très
cohérent avec lui-même parce qu'il est
un homme du KGB mais aussi un homo
sovieticus et il a été formé dans un
système où le mensonge était roi et par
ailleurs il est très cohérent par ce que
il y a effectivement vis-à-vis de
l'extérieur l'utilisation du mensonge
mais aussi vis-à-vis de l'intérieur le
le le le dispositif de propagande russe
aujourd'hui utilise en permanence le
mensonge ou en tout cas une diluion de
la vérité pour tenir sa propre
population captive de son récit de ce
qu'il veut dire sur le monde et de la
manière dont il veut présenter
ce qui est selon lui le rôle de la
Russie aujourd'hui dans le monde du 21e
siècle Pierre gonau une diplomatie du
mensonge c'est une diplomatie impossible
pour les autres pour les interlocuteurs
j' oh ben ça dépend on s'y habitude de
toute façon par exemple si on remonte au
Congrès de Vienne tout le monde montait
et Taleran était un des grands artistes
de cette diplomatie il y a le mensonge
il y a le bluff il y a des nuances
différentes queon saisit ou qu'on ne
saisit pas tout le problème c'est
jusqu'à quel point on est prisonnier de
ça et vis-à-vis des des interlocuteurs
internes aussi il y a très souvent on le
voit dans les chaînes d'information
russes on teste telle ou telle version
tel ou tel propos et on voit bien l'écho
que ça peut avoir ce n'est pas ça vient
pas du crèmeelin directement mais sent
bien que c'est pas loin Michel Valet ça
vous a frappé vous aussi en regardant ce
documentaire ça m'a frappé parce que
François Hollande le répète plusieurs
fois c'est souvent en introduction de
chaque épisode de ce documentaire cette
technique du mensonge ça m'a pas fait
tomber de ma chaise je sais pas si m'
plus que Colin Powell quand il agite un
petit flacon je sais pas siement plus
que certains responsables européens
pendant la crise grec a le film de gavra
sur Adult in the room on voit bien
comment se passent les choses aussi je
crois qu'il faut éviter la
surpsychologisation de l'analyse des
relations internationales donc je
comprends que pour le documentaire parce
qu'il faut aller droite au but en 3 He
c'est important d'un peu caractériser
les gens au sens français et anglo-saxon
il sont des personnages aussi ça dit des
choses hein ça montre comment se passe
ouais ressenti des uns et des autres
mais bon faut se garder d'un peu de
naïveté sur le sujet c'est le reproche
que vous feriez à cette série
documentaire que elle a psychologisé un
peu non pas le reproche mais le fait
faut savoir d'où parle d'où parle
lesgend d'où parle la documentariste
néanmoins ce qui est intéressant c'est
ce qui ce qui vient d'être dit c'est que
s'il assène une altterre réalité je
dirais c'est effectivement on assène une
autre vérité comme Trump à un moment a
pu se mettre à le faire aussi comme
certains dirigeants populistes il la
scène il sa le sait mais ça fait partie
quand même des de ce qu'il pose dans la
négociation et donc on part on part
d'encore plus loin Sylvie Berman il y a
autre chose qui est intéressant c'est
pas uniquement Poutine c'est le système
aussi c'est la dénégation quand la
Russie est accusée de quelque chose et
du coup il y a plusieurs versions
différentes et c'est un une forme de
manipulation parce que plus personne ne
connaîtra la vérité on est dans une
confusion permanente en disant c'est
peut-être ça mais ça peut être ça aussi
h si on continue d'explorer la
diplomatie façon Poutine il y a quand
même une exception que j'ai trouvé
éclairante dans ce film c'est cette
anecdote qui ferait presque sourire si
les enjeux n'étaient pas si graves c'est
le moment où David Cameron raconte
comment il réussit à adoucir Vladimir
Poutine en l'emmenant voir un combat de
judo lors des JO et là on sent qu'il il
il voit une facette de Vladimir Poutine
qui est un peu différente est-ce que
c'est aussi comme ça qu'on peut discuter
avec Vladimir Poutine c'est en le
séduisant vous parliez de séduction
d'ailleurs he bberman tout à l'heure ça
fait partie des clés d'entrée au
personnages bah dans les relations
internationales il y a toujours les
cadeaux les visites les belles occasions
par exemple il y avait la chasse avec
Breg Neev aussi brege Neev adorait ça et
la chasse à rambouillé c'était une arme
diplomatique aussi donc effectivement si
c'est le judo plutôt que la chasse
pourquoi pas j'allais dire Vladimir
Poutine non Antoine vitkin ouis ça fait
partie des des façons d'aborder de
d'approcher la bête j'ai envie de dire
aujourd'hui rétrospectivement on a bien
compris que ces 20 ans au pouvoir à peu
près ont correspondu à une volonté de
restauration impériale et à une
hostilité assez fondamentale à
l'Occident et à toutes ses valeurs et
ces manifestations dans le monde ça ce
sont ces objectif et ensuite il met en
œuvre un certain nombre de d'actes ça
peut passer par la diplomatie comme par
la guerre ce qu'on a vu récemment et
face à ça je crois qu'il est il l'a
montré parfaitement à l'affu de ce que
peuvent être des positions de faiblesse
de ses interlocuteurs et j'imagine que
dans son esprit encore une fois on est
dans l'anecdote mais l'anecdote fait
partie aussi des relations
internationales et de la diplomatie la
psychologie ça compte les relations
interpersonnelles ça compte plus parfois
ce qu'on le qu'on le pense en
particulier avec des dictateurs qui
n'ont de compte à rendre à personne
comme et desurs qui n'ont pas nos codes
et c'est pour ça qu'on sent une
diplomatie un peu perdu face à Poutin
quand même pour en terminer sur ce cette
anecdote effectivement je pense qu'il a
tendance à Inter interpréter un certain
nombre d'actes vis-à-vis de lui comme
des positions de faiblesse lorsqu'il
sent qu'on veut le séduire alors ça peut
ponctuellement être utile dans telle ou
telle phase de la vie diplomatique
encore une fois 24 ans de relation avec
Poutine c'est long hein on n' pas été
toujours dans dans la situation de
tension dans laquelle on est mais en
tout cas je suis à peu près certain que
il a conscience des rapports de force et
que être se montrer trop trop trop
sympathique à son égard c'est
probablement dans sa dans son esprit un
peu de Domme du KGB comme vous vous
disiez madame l'ambassadrice c'est très
certainement perçu à à juste titre comme
une position de faiblesse de son
interlocuteur est-ce que finalement il
ne respecte pas davantage les
interlocuteurs qui font preuve de de
fort tempérament et de force plus que de
faiblesse vous disiez ou de séduction ou
de ou qui accepte de poser certains
comment dire certains présupposés avec
lui il y a un moment il passe assez vite
dessus mais il y a un moment où Boris
Johnson dit au début de la la discussion
un peu en le disant comme si c'est
conseillé lu avait conseillé puis pour
passer à autre chose je lui redis à quel
point la Russie a été l'Union soviétique
a été importante dans la lutte commune
avec la Grande-Bretagne contre le
nazisme ça lui a beaucoup plu je sais
plus comment il dit les choses bon il aé
c'est un élément extrêmement important
c'està-dire que le judo je ne sais pas
si David Cameron passe pour un fanfaron
auprès de Poutine ou si au contraire
sincèrement tel que l'a ressenti Cameron
il a été sensible à ça ça leur a permis
de discuter mais il est bien évident que
reconnaître quand même dans le passé
qu'elle a été le poids de l'Union
soviétique c'est peut-être sans parler
de séduction ement une des choses que
nous n'avons que nous avons moins su
faire ou pas assez dans le cadre des
relations avec Vladimir Poutine ce qu'on
comprend en tout cas très bien dans ce
film c'est que Vladimir Poutine a
clairement une dent contre l'Occident
qu'il nourrit une rancœur ancienne le
mot rancœur d'ailleurs est employé qu'il
a eu l'impression d'être méprisé d'être
mise à l'écart alors question les
puissances occidentales ont-elles des
torts ont-elles été maladroite parfois
humiliante je vous propose de réécouter
l'avis de José Manuel Baroso après les
propos de bar Obama qualifiant la Russie
de puissance régionale c'est un moment
important du film
écoutez selon lui la Russie n'est qu'une
puissance régionale ce n'est pas utile
de le dire ça nourrit une certaine
rancœur et pour moi Poutine est
essentiellement un produit de la rancœur
à cause du déclin et aussi de
l'humiliation de la Russie après
l'effondrement de l'Union
soviétique quel est l'intérêt d'humilier
ou de créer plus de renœur chez
quelqu'un comme Poutine
c'est intéressant la question que pose
José Emmanuel Baroso pierre gonau c'est
presque une pierre dans le jardin des
Occidentaux là c'est quel était le
besoin de Barack Obama d'humilier en
parlant de puissance régionale d'umilier
Vladimir Poutine oui alors ce sont des
catégories évidemment qui heurent
effectivement si on dit aussi que la
France est une puissance régionale on y
est peut-être habitué maintenant mais à
une certaine époque on l'aurait très mal
pris ça c'est c'est certain ce que je
dirais aussi c'est que il y ara vraiment
un rapport très ambigu de Vladimir
Poutine à l'URSS d'un côté il en est
l'héritier il a été formé par elle et de
l'autre malgré tout quand il évoque en
particulier l'Ukraine il a une d aussi
contre l'énine il faut pas oublier de le
dire en disant l'énine a créé cette
Ukraine c'est totalement artificiel il
n'aurait pas dû et là il est un peu pris
entre la rhétorique de yelsin qui
ressuscite la Russie au détriment d'une
URSS qui avait opprimé la Russie c'était
vraiment la position à ce moment-là et
la logique de l'Empire où évidemment ben
la Russie n'est qu'une composante de
l'Empire au fond même si elle est la
plus importante et où ce qui compte
c'est effectivement d'avoir l'Empire le
plus large possible alors à ce moment-là
le fait qu'on est donné à l'Ukraine
telle et telle province n'a aucune
importance c'est simplement une question
d'opportunité et là il est entre ces
deux et certainement que ça l'a aussi
handicapé pour aboutir à une position
claire et donc aussi il faut quand même
voir que souvent il renvoie sur
l'Occident ses propres impasses h Michel
Valet est-ce que l'Occident emploie
parfois des techniques de provocation
qui sont peut-être un peu maladroite
quand on s'adresse à Vladimir Poutine
alors c'est une des limites de
l'exercice de dans le cadre de ce
documentaire là mais bon un moment il
faut choisir un un angle ouis c'est
qu'on ne parle pas d'avant
2014 et on ne parle pas de toute la
décennie 2000 c'est ubert Vedrine qui
dit que on a plus AFF faaire aujourd'hui
à la même Russie que celle à laquelle
nous avions àaire dans les années 2000
mais qu'on a peut-être loupé le cor à un
moment sur le fait d'essayer de les
ancrer un peu plus le documentaire ne
repasse pas les images du discours de
Poutine devant le parlement allemand et
cetera et pour Poutine et pour ceux qui
sont d'accord avec lui parce que le ce
qu'il faut voir aussi c'est qu'en union
je l'ai dit en Russie et parce que les
médias ne sont pas libres et parce que
il y a un appareil détail de propagande
qui est ce qu'il est néanmoins Poutine
n'est pas sans soutien je il gagne pas
les les élections de manière honnête
peut-être mais je suis pas sûr qu'il les
gagnerait pas non plus si si on je ne
suis pas sûr voilà bon donc tout ça pour
dire que je ne suis pas persuadé qu'il y
ait une utilité à la déclaration de
Barack Obama de la même façon que
certains russes notamment antoire je
Poutine restent avec l'idée de cette
espèce d'afron qui a été le four rire de
de Bill Clinton avec avec Boris Helsin
ou l'absence de dirigeants européens et
occidentaux en 2015 pour l'anniversaire
de la grande guerre patriotique si vous
voulez voilà les sanctions on peut
toujours en discuter ce sont des sujets
très compliqués est-ce que les sanctions
de 2014 il fallait les faire cell
d'aujourd'hui c'est un autre sujet mais
est-ce que ça nourrit qu'est-ce que ça
amène dans les buts qu'on cherche à
obtenir de discussions de maintien de la
paix de cranter des des principes est-ce
que ça sert à quelque chose dans ces
moments-là oou est-ce que puisque il y a
une approche psychologante du
psychologisante du documentaire les
hommes et les femmes qui qui qui
négocient sont des hommes et des femmes
donc il peut y avoir un peu du Briss
presque même des fois de la part d'un
président américain ça peut arriver il
faut en tenir compte si
oui tout à fait il y avait chez euh
Barack Obama une volonté d'humilier la
Russie effectivement à tort euh oui à
tort euh il n'avait pas besoin de de
s'exprimer de de cette manière-là
d'ailleurs sidingping fait l'inverse au
contraire il reconnaît que la Russie est
une puissance mondiale c'est la
dimension psychologique et d'ailleurs
euh Jacques Chirac qui avait de bonnes
relations avec Poutine au début a
toujours abordé ses interlocuteurs en
disant que c'était un grand pays qui il
aimait et cetera et c'était pas
uniquement sur beaucoup de différence
sur la Russie et c'est important donc
moi j'ai vécu jusqu'en 89 en Russie
c'était la période de la pérest Troïa et
ensuite ça a été bah le l'échec et
l'explosion du du pays et j'ai revu les
les mêmes personnes aux nations- unies à
ce moment-là et qui avaient ce sentiment
d'humiliation parce qu'on écoutait plus
la Russie effectivement et ce qui est
intéressant c'est que en fait euh il
n'aimait pas particulièrement le Union
soviétique ce qu'il appréciait c'était
la puissance du pays puisque c'était une
relation bipire et
son et il a dit d'ailleurs ceux qui
regrettent l'Union soviétique n'ont pas
de raison et ceux qui ne la regrettent
pas n'ont pas de cœur donc c'est assez
intéressant et je pense qu'il est plus
intéressé par la puissance de la Russie
que on parle même dans le film enfin
dans le documentaire de volonté de
recréer l'Union soviétique pas du tout
c'est il est pas du tout intéressé par
les pays qui n'appartiennent pas à l'air
culturel russe ça il l'a parfaitement
admis mais c'est la puissance
effectivement de la Russie que
sabreginski l'a écrit hein qu' ne voyait
pas sans l'Ukraine Antoine vitkin et
Pierre gonau oui il faut jamais
sous-estimer la la force du ressentiment
parmi d'ailleurs un certain nombre de de
puissances dans le monde aujourd'hui je
me souviens pour mon propre documentaire
j'ai rencontré un de ses conseillers qui
m'a dit que Poutine avait été très
humilié parce que lorsqu'il avait
rencontré pour la première fois fois
Obama il avait essayé lui de dire
quelques mots à Obama en en anglais et
Obama n'avait pas fait le moindre effort
pour lui dire un mot en en russe je
peut-être qu'il a pas il a été humilié
mais encore une fois je pense que ce
discours m'était destiné à moi français
c'était une manière de dire vous nous
avez humilié ce qui est je pense
parfaitement instrumentalisé par Poutine
et les siens il n'est pas Poutine dans
une cours d'école il sait que nous
savons que nous ne sommes pas dans une
cour d'école et la question de d'être
humilié par pour vous ça compte pas
alors je je suis pas en train de vous
dire que ça compte pas mais ce que je
vous dis c'est que c'est instrumentalisé
utilisé et c'est caractéristique cette
manière de présenter les les choses
Poutine est quelqu'un de parfaitement
que c'est pas une manière de nous
remettre en question nous dans notre
diplomatie nous ocdentaux par ailleurs
c'est un argument rhtorique encore une
fois qui correspond à un ressentiment
russe est utilisé face à nous mais je
crois que Poutine est d'abord humilié
par l'échec du système auquel il a cru
qui était l'Union soviétique il veut
absolument pas la restaurer je suis
parfaitement d'accord avec ça veut
restaurer la puissance russe mais il a
vécu le le l'effondrement de de l'Union
soviétique de sa jeunesse qui était une
puissance respectée à l'échelle mondiale
et comme il a du mal à proposer à sa
population un projet qui soit un
développement économique ou un
développement démocratique et bien il
leur propose presque par complexe vous
êtes en train un projet nationaliste et
donc il utilise cette thématique de de
l'humiliation encore une fois je crois
qu'il en est largement responsable je je
ne crois pas que l'Occident en tout cas
à la chute de l'Union soviétique les
Américains ont pris d'immenses
précautions pour justement ne pas
humilier l'Union soviétique enfin la
Russie naissante de l'Union soviétique
pour l'inclure dans des dispositifs
internationaux pour et cetera bon qui
ait eu enfin encore une fois la
psychologie ça ça ça compte dans les
relations internationales et dans la
dans la vie des états et dans dans la
tête des rus très certainement mais
encore une fois je pense que les Russes
effectivement ont ce sentiment là en
particulier une population russe qui a
connu cette époque peut-être moins les
jeunes mais Poutine s'appuie sur eux
donc Poutine en joue mais voilà c'est je
moi je je si voulez je récu cette notion
de de faute commise d'humiliation je
pense que les intérêts ont des états
Poutine pardon les les États ont des
intérêts enfin les intérêts parfois en
des états c'est vrai vous connaissez la
phrase sur sur sur la Russie d'ailleurs
sur le les services secrets ont un état
parfois c'est les états bref et encore
une fois nous avons nous aussi
occidentaux des intérêts nos intérêts
ont pe conduire par exemple à à à mettre
en place une alliance politique au
militaire avec l'Ukraine par exemple ce
sont nos intérêtsér
de puissance qui ne sont pas ceux de la
Russie et donc substituer le discours de
l'humiliation à celui des intérêts des
états je crois que c'est ça ne même pas
à grand-chose en tout cas c'est utilisé
par Poutine ça c'est sûr mais ça ne mène
pas à grand-chose pierre Gon oui alors
plusieurs choses peut-être rapidement
premièrement c'est que effectivement
reconstituer l'Union soviétique ce qu'il
ne reconstitue pas c'est l'idéologie
communiste ça on est bien d'accord et le
projet socialiste c'est plus à l'ordre
du jour mais territorialement les pays
baltes sont quand même parce qu'il y a
des minorités russes
euh virtuellement euh travaillable aussi
euh le caucas quand même avec la
geéorgie en dépessant la Géorgie le
Kazakhstan alors c'est un grand ami mais
s'il a l'air de s'émanciper ça ne va pas
d'autant plus que là aussi il y a toute
une partie du Kazakhstan que même sol
genénitsine qui pourtant disait laissons
tomber l'Empire même sol genénicde ne
revendiquait tout le nord du Kazakhstan
en disant c'est le sud de la Sibérie
vous voyez
facile de changer la terminologie et
puis une autre chose quand
même que je me permets de dire c'est que
on a quand on dit ça on a humilié
l'Occident et cetera on a toujours
l'impression que par exemple tous les
pays qui ont adhéré à l'OTAN c'est
simplement une manœuvre de l'OTAN mais
ces gens ont voulu entrer dans l'UTAN et
pour les tchèqus les Polonais les Baltes
ils étaient très pressés d'y entrer
parce que pour eux c'était la seule
garantie de ne plus retourner dans
l'URSS c'est exactement précis c'est
qu'il ne supporte porte pas c'est sa
terreur de voir l'Ukraine un jour
intégrer l'OTAN qui le fait peut-être
déclencher cette guerre oui et je veux
dire par là que ce n'est pas simplement
l'OTAN qui instrumentalise ces pays il y
a une volonté de ces pays fort de tout
ça moi je j'ai encore du mal à
comprendre pourquoi on a été si surpris
par le déclenchement de cette guerre en
Ukraine alors Michel Valet écoutez moi
je ENF normalement un politique ne ne
devrait pas dire ça mais moi je me suis
trompé lourdement j'aurais mis mes deux
mains à couper la veille de du
déclenchement ou n'était
pas que il trouve son intérêt dans le
fait de faire couler du sang de civil
blanc orthodoxe russophone alors que
tout semblait écrit tout semblait se
mettre en place progressivement ce
documentaire le montre un réarmement des
provocations la boîte de Pandore ouverte
en août 2013 quand la ligne rouge est
franchie avec les armes chimiques
documentire il est fait après coup si
vous voulez bon c'est que on réécrit la
la logique de ce qui s'est passé après
coup donc il faut bien essayer de
montrer des des grands rouge je
l'entends néanmoins je crois que je suis
pas le seul à avoir été persuadé que et
peut-être qu'il faut chercher plus loin
il y a un poème dem qui dit
littéralement que la la Russie est
imprévisible don tact mais aussi
peut-être parce que vous avez dit tout à
l'heure nous n'avons pas ils n'ont pas
nos codes oui enfin on n pas les leurs
non plus si on ne fait pas l'effet
l'effort de se mettre à la place de
l'autre ce qui et de chercher la
complexité dans l'autre ce qui est
autant le rôle des romanciers que des
diplomates Sylv ber oui alors quand on
parle
de de l'intérêt des états des hommes
d'État euh parfois c'est pas l'intérêt
finalement qui domine mais plutôt les
passions parce que si on regarde après
coup c'était pas l'intérêt de de Poutine
de déclencher cette guerre et c'est le
constat que peut-être dans sa tête il
fait aujourd'hui même s'il est dans une
dans une fuite en avant je crois que
l'autre raison c'est que les Ukrainiens
n'y croyaient absolument pas moi j'étais
à Kiev puisque j'étais médiatrice de
l'OSCE sur la restitution du Dombas au
sein de l'Ukraine avec un statut spécial
et euh donc 3 semaines avant l'entourage
de Zelinski que j'ai vu euh disait que
c'était hors de question que la Russie
attaque euh à grande échelle le K enfin
l'Ukraine et Kiev peut-être dans le
donbas mais euh mais ils n'y croyaient
pas euxmêm n croyent pas non eux-mêmes
n'y croyaient pas et tous c'est-à-dire
toutes les personnes parce qu'on leur a
posé la question parceque évidemment euh
il y avait ces ce déploiement de troupes
massif les États-Unis ni le Royaume-Uni
avait commencé à évacuer leurs
ambassades et même ce que on nous
rapportait c'est que Zelenski était
furieux parce que justement ça affectait
l'économie ou le tourisme ukrainien
est-ce que l'Occident est alors un peu
naïf vis-à-vis de de de Vladimir Poutine
et de de ce dirigeant je je parle de
naïveté parce que nous avons des codes
plutôt pacifiques en Europe et et aux
États-Unis et tant mieux mais notre
pacifisme tranche avec cet esprit
guerrier qu' a tout toujours non je
crois pas qu'on soit plus pacifiste que
que que d'autres enfin oui nous vivons
dans des sociétés en paix donc nous
avons forcément du mal à à accepter le
fait que la guerre puisse faire partie
de notre de notre univers mais je crois
surtout je suis entièrement d'accord
avec vous que moins que de la de la
naïveté effectivement nous avons une
pensée enfin nous avons une une pensée
de rationalité économique comm étant
finalement
le la la logique qui nous constitue
c'estautrement dit nous considérons que
personne n'a intérêt à aller contre ce
que sont ses intérêts d'abord ses
intérêts économiques effectivement ça a
été beaucoup ça mais c'était lié aussi
au fait qu'après 2014 la réponse avait
été pour pour une large part des des
sanctions doncc une fois encore une fois
dans C dans cet ordre économique avec
cette idée que finalement l'économie
l'économie c'est ce qui au bout du
compte importeou et donc nous avons eu
effectivement peut-être un peu de
difficulté à considérer qu'il puisse
aller contre ce qui était ses intérêts
mais j'aurais plutôt enfin j'aurais
tendance à tempérer cela encore une fois
j'ai pas le j'ai j'ai aucune vérité mais
je meis j'ai essayé de me faire
expliquer par quelquesuns de ses proches
la prise de décision en 2014 de
l'invasion de la Crimée bon il y a eu
une prise de décision il y a eu il y a
eu certainement des hésitations il y a
eu un choix qui a été fait il est pas
fou c'est pas on peut imaginer que
s'agissant de 22 ça s'est passé de la
même manière ça veut dire que
effectivement il y a il y a une tendance
de fond une tendance politique de fond
et puis il y a un choix et ce choix
était appu sur le fait qu'il pensait
gagner et qu'encore une fois on l'a su
non mais on l'a su après ça s'est pas
joué à grand-chose Kiev aurait pu tomber
donc il pensait réussir ce qu'il avait
déjà commencé à faire en 2014
c'est-à-dire grignoter l'Ukraine pour
lui la guerre a commencé en 2014 pour
les Ukrainiens la guerre a commencé en
2014 pas en 2022 comme on l'a
effectivement trop rapidement pensé ici
en voyant ses troupes masser à la
frontièreman je vous ai vu réagir alors
les raisons que vous évoquez sont tout à
fait valable il y en a une autre c'est
le
départ catastrophique des Américains de
Kabou et ça effectivement ils sont dit
et il s'est dit jamais les Américains
n'interviendront en plus Joe Biden avait
dit à un moment l'Ukraine n'est pas
membre de l'OTAN et il avait ajouté et
si c'est une petite incursion et
probablement s'il avait commencé par le
donbas personne
n'auraitagag et la Kief c'était choant
donc ce qu'il faut dire c'est que
effectivement 2014 ça a été un succès
pour la Crimée hein sans bavure et qui a
énormément remonté la popularité de
Poutine parce qu'elle était nettement
plus bas en Russie et en plus dans
l'émigration russse là même à Paris on a
vu des gens qui commençaient à ironiser
un peu il revient là ces élections
truqué c'est ridicule ah oui là donc ça
ça ça a étéit un point un bon point
disons pour lui alors après il y a
effectivement l'idée que l'Ukraine
allait s'effondrer et au fond remettre
sur le trône un yanukovic ou un autre
avec en plus l'appui du donbas qui à ce
moment-là resterait dans une Ukraine
satellisée c'était pas absurde il y a
deux stratégies et au fond là aussi
c'est pas défini est-ce que on coupe
l'Ukraine par petit morceau en tranche
jusqu'à ce queon a pris et puis la bande
côtière il y a des des plans très
ambitieux ou bien est-ce que on la garde
telle qu'elle est ou à peu près eu et à
ce moment-là il faut qu'on ait un régime
favorable et il y en a eu en Ukraine
pendant temps bien sû tout tout cela
nous amène on va on va avancer un petit
peu vers la troisè partie de notre
échange à la situation explosive
d'aujourd'hui une guerre en Ukraine qui
s'installe dans la durée des tensions
immenses au Proche-Orient depuis les
massacres du 7 octobre il est
intéressant d'ailleurs de voir comment
Vladimir Poutine a lâché néaniaahou et
consolider ses liens avec l'Iran et la
Chine de voir comment il préfèrent
séduire les puissances Arab ou les
régimes autoritaires à quoi joue le chef
du kremelin je vous pose la question
après cet extrait qui nous rappelle dans
le film toujours ce lien très fort avec
la Chine le Premier ministre chinois et
Poutine se sont opposés d'une même voix
à l'expansion de l'OTAN les deux hommes
ont affirmé que les liens entre leurs
pays n'avaient pas de
limite il a envoyé un message très fort
en disant que la Chine était désormais
un partenaire et un soutien encore plus
proche de la Russie cette déclaration
n'a fait que souligner l'importance de
défendre le principe que chaque nation a
le droit de choisir sa propre
voie ma question va être très directe
est-ce qu'on est en train d'assister à
la naissance à la construction d'un axe
des dictature mené par un Vladimir
Poutine contre les
démocraties Val néanmoins dans le
documentaire ce qu'on voit est-ce qu'on
oublie peut-être un petit peu de dire
c'est qu'il quand même rien d'épatant à
ce que les les Russes se tournent en
étant un peu isol olé vers les Chinois
parce qu'il quand même une histoire
idéologique un peu commune à un moment
avec Bachar elAssad je trouve qu' on
aurait dû rappeler que enfin des des
Syriens qui parlent rus et des étudiants
Syriens à l'époque communistes qui
allaient à Moscou et les échanges qui se
faisaient y compris avec l'Afrique de
l'Ouest on a un moment beaucoup fait de
focus sur la déstabilisation de
l'Afrique de l'Ouest par Poutine ou
plutôt par Wagner où ce qu'il en reste
façon puzzle aujourd'hui notamment
pourprix googine tout ça est un ensemble
qui répond à une histoire plus longue
que la simple décennie qui vient de
s'écouler donc oui nous sommes dans un
moment qui où par exemple on peut plus
prendre de de résolution au Conseil de
sécurité pour essayer de régler les
problèmes à quelques grandes ce monde
parce qu'il y a le véau russe qui est
presque plus compliqué que le véau
chinois maintenant à à lever donc oui il
y a une forme de d'instabilité et et et
il y a un défi à tout le moins il y a un
défi pour les démocraties ça c'est
certain oui je suis entièrement d'accord
avec ce qui vient d'être dit euh
aujourd'hui il est peut-être en train
d'assister à un échec à soutenir
l'Ukraine dans la durée l'avenir ne le
dira mais je crois que malheureusement
on en est là mais donc il y a ce défi là
c'est autrement dit quel est quel
système est le plus efficace et le plus
fort et shijinping et Poutine
effectivement prétendent et veulent
veulent prétendre et veulent dire et
veulent dire à une partie de nos
opinions que ce sont eux les plus forts
et les plus efficace donc ce lien très
fort ne surprend personne pierre gonau
oui mais en même temps je dirais qu'il
est pas si lisse que ça déjà entre la
Russie et la Chine il y a des peurs les
Russes ont très peurs des Chinois et
quand Poutine est allé juste avant
d'envahir l'Ukraine en Chine certains
avaient commenté ça de manière ça y est
il vend la Russie et ses ressources
minières et la Sibérie au chinois donc
la peur de l'inversion d'un rapport qui
traditionnellement mettrait la Russie au
sommet de ce monde non démocratique elle
existe d'autre part avec l'Iran il y a
effectivement une conjonction d'intérêt
pour les importations d'armes pour
l'hostilité à l'Amérique mais la Russie
et l'Iran ont toujours été en
concurrence hein dans bien des domaines
et alors en particulier au carabach
l'Iran soutient l'Arménie qui peu de
soutien mais soutient l'Arménie donc et
il y a la Turquie n'oublions pas qui
joue son jeu aussi donc là la
résurrection des empires elle est pas
forcément dans l'unité est-ce qu'on
assiste à un combat des modèles Syvie
Berman le modèle démocratique versus un
modèle
dictatorial on a tendance à le dire en
tout cas et Joe Biden et puis c'est
c'est une tendance très très américaine
puisque madelineright autrefois le le
voulait aussi c'est-à-dire de d'avoir
une alliance de démocrati contre les
systèmes autoritaires en réalité ça ne
marche pas du tout d'abord parce que les
démocraties sont vraiment très
minoritaires il y a 193 pays aux
Nations-Unies il y a peut-être une
trentaine de de véritables démocrati
mais effectivement c'est le le le choc
entre plusieurs modèles et ça ça se joue
dans ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui le sud
global et le Sud global finalement bah
considère que le modèle chinois est un
modèle qui fonctionne bien parce que
c'est la croissance et sans sans la
démocratie puisque la plupart des pays
dans ces régions ne sont pas
nécessairement démocratiques mais le
rapprochement entre la Russie et la
Chine est lié à l'hostilité de Donald
Trump aux États-Unis au pardon aux
Chinois et aux Russes parce que c'est
vrai que il n'y a pas d'entente évidente
il y a pas d'amour perdu entre les deux
peuples qui se comprennent assez mal
mais le choix de sidingping comme celui
de Poutine et celui de considérer que
l'ennemi de mon ennemi est mon ami et
donc de développer cette relation qui
n'existait pas encore dans ces termes il
y a quelques années une toute dernière
question pour conclure cet échange parce
que le temps a filé trop vite est-ce que
Vladimir Poutine a préparé sa succession
est-ce que on sait qui après Vladimir
Poutine midée je crois que le peuple le
peuple le propre de de l'homme
autoritaire euh pour le dire de manière
ehimistique c'est précisément de penser
que il est indépassable et qu'on peut
pas lui succéder donc ils vivent dans
une peur probablement inavouée du fait
que en fait une fois qu'on a plus le
pouvoir faut installer des gens qui vous
permettent de ne pas être chassé ou
traqué c'est un peu ce que yelsin qui
n'était pas un dictateur euh qui était
plutôt un démocrate dans l'idée après il
s'est passé ce qui s'est passé mais
yelsine mais en la famille yelsine met
en place quelqu'un qui n'ira pas leur
chercher de complication derrière mais
ce sont des transitions toujours
difficiles à à effectuer et autour de
Poutine y compris dans des états voisins
je citerai par exemple un pays qu'on ne
cite jamais où il y a un vrai sujet
notamment du fait du nombre
impressionnant de prisonniers politiques
qui est le Bélarus au Bélarus on le on
le voit bien le le le la personne qui
est à la tête du Bélarus Alexandre
Lukachenko non non sauf son fils
éventuellement n'envisage pas qu'on lui
succède et c'est ce qui fait au bout
d'un moment le pourrissement des des
situations maintenant dans l'entourage
de Poutine d'après ce qu'on a vu dans
les différentses documentaires et
informations depuis le déclenchement de
la guerre en Ukraine il y a un état de
paranoïa tel qui finit presque par faire
penser à l'état de paranoïa stalinien
qu'on pu décrire qu'on pu décrire
certains à la fin de la vie de de
Staline sans faire de raccourci quoi
tout le monde est d'accord avec ça oui
et je crois que pour préciser que son
avenir est indexé sur la réussite ou
l'échec de sa guerre en Ukraine ou et
c'est pour ça qu'elle est j'ai du mal à
encore une fois je peux me tromper hein
je suis pas en train de dire dans une
boule de cristal j'ai du mal mal à
imaginer qu'il puisse rester au pouvoir
après avoir subi ce qui serait un grave
échec en Ukraine pour l'instant il est
dans un
demi-échec il essaie de transformer en
oui en demi-vctoire dans la mesure où il
n'a pas réussi à à faire chuter et à
conquérir KF qui était son objectif
politique et militaire principal et
qu'on arrive au 2è anniversaire de cette
guerre voilà mais comme il a un petit
peu de flexibilité en ce qui concerne
les objectifs de la guerre peut très
bien faire valoir que le maintien de de
la Crimée est sans doute d'une
bande côtière dans le Dombas
constituerait une une
victoire c'est lui qui c'est lui qui
décidera de ce qu'est la victoire sauf
si c'était un échec majeur et que les
troupes russes étaient complètement
chassé
d'ukraineusion Ben je pense aussi que il
faut le rappeler il a 70 ans et c'est
peut-être pour ça aussi qu'il était
pressé de déclencher cette guerre pour
couronner son œuvre donc on est dans une
fin de règne voilà une belle phrase de
conclusion merci merci à tous les quatre
d'avoir participé à cette émission merci
beaucoup à vous de nous avoir suivi
comme chaque semaine émission et
documentaire à retrouver en replay sur
notre plateforme
publicsenat.fr à très vite merci à
[Musique]
bientôt